let me ask you this is what I have
chunky old five right you have in front
of you the success and the success
awesome is there any reason for me to
get the 6s awesome or could I just get
the success the six that well success or
6i sauces wait you're talking about the
plus i plus he's no guest I decided to
call the success awesome I've been using
the regular sized phone for many many
many years but I gotta tell you I
switched the plus and it makes a huge
difference it's much easier instead of
axle animals like your iPad you don't
actually have to have carry both you can
really read the news you go in look at
web pages it really makes a difference
and the size is not that much bigger
okay so what's the selling point for
consumers that well the selling point
for consumers first of all the selling
point is we talk about the larger phone
or you're talking about the new S
version because the s version actually
has a lot more than the typical ass it's
much much faster the touch finger to a
recognition works much better it has
this new feature with Siri where to just
say hey Siri and it will react to you
without having to push any buttons or
anything else so it's really quite a
nice can you hold them up cuz ya so this
this is if they look identical I mean
this is this the new one yeah and this
is I put them both on and this this is
the new one and this is the original
plus but this one so i dint
hardware-wise they're identical but
what's behind the scenes on this thing
is much nice for example it's got the 3d
touch on it so if I'm looking at email I
can touch the email go right in the
email have to go and open it up it has
the Serie we don't have to don't have to
actually push the button for Syria just
talk to it the fingerprint works much
much better much faster the whole
overall the phone is much much faster so
um Apple always plays a very coy game of
expectations right they manage it so
people are lined up outside that's what
the impression what do we know about
pre-orders what is what hard data do we
have about whether this thing is going
to sell it's hard to say because they
didn't just start with a new phone as
they normally do they also changed the
way they sell it so this is an unlocked
phone so there's a big reason to go
there now so if you travel
internationally you really want the
unlocks you don't actually have to make
this on any carrier why did they make
that change well they wanted to get into
the business of actually leasing the
phone and North's interesting verizon
and AT&T and Sprint all followed
immediately so they started saying guess
what instead of
buying the phone pay us 40 some dollars
a month depending on the size of the
phone forever and forever and every year
when the new phone goes up we'll swap it
out so you can the old one will give you
a new owners keep on paying us they want
to get into the leasing business mark
it's just as good of a deal when you
lease a car same idea it's really it's
really what's happening here and and by
the way in sona's Apple started doing
that Verizon jumped on the bandwagon
t-mobile jumped on the bandwagon sprint
jumped on the bandwagon